on ne peut pas s'interdire à l'avance
d'utiliser un moyen qui le jour venu et
c'est à dire dans un s'est longtemps
hélas nous permettrait de réussir le
déconfinement après avoir réussi le
confinement
il faut bien sûr abordé avec beaucoup de
précaution de circonspection je dirais
et la commission des lois s'est organisé
pour le faire elle a mis en place un
binôme de rapporteur sur la protection
des données privées
elle va auditionner la présidente de la
cnil et je crois que c'est très
important de le faire parce qu'elle
connaît bien par fonction ces questions
elle décidera aussi des experts et les
visionnera le secrétaire d'état cédric
au qui comme vous le signalez tout à
l'heure s'est publiquement prononcé mais
j'ai relevé qu'il l'avait fait avec une
certaine prudence au fond nous ne devons
pas nous précipiter vers l'utilisation
de moyens dont il n'est pas prouvé
qu'ils seront efficaces si ils doivent
de surcroît poser des problèmes
insurmontables de liberté individuelle
et de protection des données privées
mais ça ne nous interdit pas de regarder
plus en détail cette question parce
qu'on ne peut pas non plus se priver de
la possibilité d'avancer pour que ce
fléau du coc vide 19 soit vaincue vous
avez également posé une question tout à
l'heure en deux parties l'une des
parties est bien porté sur les ehpad où
on en a déploré vous l'avez dit
malheureusement situation mortifère
qu'avez vous pensé de la réponse
d'olivier ferrand qui a bien dit qu'en
droit il y avait la possibilité d'avoir
une personne à côté du mourant pour
l'accompagner dans les derniers instants
si elle a les équipements de protection
mais malheureusement on voit bien que le
problème ce sont ces équipements de
protection
ce sont les masques que non même pas les
personnels encadrant dans certains ehpad
il va de soi que c'est un problème qui
est extrêmement sensible pour tous les
français savoir ce que nos aînés vont
devenir si
ils ne sont pas protégés quand ils sont
pris en charge par un personnel très
dévoué mais qui n'a lui même pas reçu de
masques en nombre suffisant et puis il
suffit pas d'en livrer une fois il faut
que tous les jours on puisse changer ses
masques pour pouvoir être efficace
or le gouvernement avait annoncé que ça
y est ça y était les ehpad allait
fonctionner avec des masques et nous
avons constaté dans nos départements
mais nous constatons aussi par les
auditions que nous faisons la commission
des affaires sociales a reçu ce matin
une personnalité très importante madame
montchamp présidente de la caisse de
solidarité pour l'autonomie signal
s'occupe de tout de tous les
établissements pour personnes âgées et
pour handicapés et elle a ce qui met
elle aussi que la situation n'était pas
réglée pour l'approvisionnement régulier
à une seule fois mais régulier en masque
de l'ensemble des maisons pour personnes
âgées et pour personnes handicapées